how long ago Kevin was the general plot
outline for this film devised well uh in
a very very general way probably five or
six years ago on a on a little creative
retreat that we had the idea of adapting
the Infinity Gauntlet paying off with
Joss Whedon had teased at the end of the
first Avengers with fan oohs and that
story being so big that we could do two
movies specifically outlining it was
these two gentlemen during production of
civil war is when that started the Chris
are there characters that you and Steve
got to write for in this film I mean
obviously ant-man you've never written
before I don't not not explore Civil War
right but were there any that you got to
write for more I guess extensively or
for the first time period that you were
particularly excited about I guess we
the ancient one is for the first time
it's always a pleasure to write for
tilda swinton cuz you know you know
it'll sound so much better than it does
when you say it no other were it was
more of oh good this one's back where I
can you know anytime you get to write
for Howard Stark I'm just happy no
matter who's playing well and most
impressively it was the
reinterpretations of characters like
Thor and Hulk in the in the post five
years section of the film Joe from your
point of view you and your brother were
there things directorial II or
technically that you guys purposely kind
of saved for this last film it's it's
hard to quote-unquote save something
because if you don't make a great movie
there's not gonna be a next movie so
you're really putting all of your energy
and effort and thought into each film I
mean it what's unique about this is this
is a narrative experiment that has
spanned over ten years and it's built
I think it's built a unique amount of
emotional capital with audiences and
momentum and so if we're saving anything
for endgame it was
the end and on the fact that we were
able to bring closure to a franchise and
I think you know kudos to Kevin kudos to
Disney there's been a series of very
disruptive choices made an extremely
extremely expensive movies civil war we
took these very popular characters and
we pit them against each other and
turned Iron Man into a villain at the
end of infinity war we killed half the
characters at the end of endgame those
no spoilers obviously because you all
just watched it you know we killed we're
not used to that we still we still are
being secretive and we're going honey no
they just saw golly look at the numbers
everybody just saw we killed arguably
the most popular character in pop
culture and I think you know I would
argue that these are brave choices for
commercial content given the fact that
the visuals on this film are just and
all of the films are just so spectacular
as screenwriters how much if at all are
you in contact with the visual effects
technicians during the writing process
to be like well we're thinking of
writing this could is this even feasible
or is it they get the script and have to
make it work they're very connected once
the first draft is in and you know we've
seen the twenty one preceding movies
they can't do anything and the biggest
hurdle was boy if Thanos doesn't really
work as a character as a living as a
human in effect this is gonna lose a lot
of the gravity that we needed to carry
and I remember when they showed us the
very first test where they had gotten
Josh Brolin in and famoust him I don't
understand the technology they press a
button marked vanos and they turns into
that that's how it works
there's one on your computer you just
dig around for and it was staggering and
it was like I felt so much better after
that five minutes but oh this is all
possible now and we can do whatever we
can write with
we want but generally we will write a
first draft and then it goes out to them
and then they have much better ideas
about how to stage things or we've
written it small because effectively we
don't I don't know that you can put
50,000 spaceships up there so we say you
know one bad guy and then they go
wee-wee-wee think maybe this and it that
we should do that and stephen also the
other thing about the script it's just
the way you guys masterfully balance so
many main characters i'm talking of the
handful of major characters and their
storylines when you're working on it are
you actually looking at script pages and
being and saying to yourself okay we
haven't seen hawkeye in X amount of
pages let's make sure that that's fixed
or is it more of just how it's feeling
to you in a gut way how do I say this
in this particular movie you can see why
it's three hours because of the second
act right you can't skip a stone you
know when you make that decision I'm
gonna go back and get do all of them and
hopefully those will be emotional
stories not just shopping trips right so
the the page count for that tends to
balance out you know at the end but I
would say the the blending of it or the
decision where things that go is often
certainly Joan ant but a lot of its Jeff
Ford our editor who is just great at
figuring out emotionally where the story
wants to go so we've often handed him
second acts that are sort of collective
and he makes them specific and speaking
of emotion Joe I think such a lot of the
beauty of this film lies in the
emotional impact of the time travel
sequences and that's the stuff that I
really found myself attaching to were
you guys fully aware at the script level
that that was going to be in some ways a
lot of the emotional heart of the film
or did that kind of become clear to you
as you were shooting it no in the script
phase look we knew that when there was a
lot of emotional capital built up over
the years we knew
that by revisiting some of those
sequences that there would be a certain
attraction for the audience but you know
as Steve said if you're not infusing it
with with character and with choices the
characters have to make and motivation
ultimately it just becomes a series of
plot and the clip show and a clip show
you know so it
we had to seed emotion in in them
revisiting the past and you know
especially with thorat it moves his
character forward when he revisits his
mother on the day that she's about to
die Tony getting closure with his father
cap seeing Peggy which ultimately
probably led to the choice at the end of
the movie so all of these moments are
significant and and I think you know
again Tony without seeing his father and
having that moment with his father you
know I don't know that he would've been
in the place to put on the gauntlet and
and and kill himself so there's a direct
line you know from you know all the
stuff we were doing in civil war to
infinity war to to everything and an end
game for for all of those characters
especially for Tony Stark and Steve
Rogers when you look at the entire
sprawling cast of this by my count eight
oscar-winning actors and actresses in
the cast who's the one person in the
cast when you watch the movie that it
just blows your mind that they're in
this movie I think it's Robert Redford's
last time on film like you know we could
announce that ahead of time but you know
yeah he told us the day that he shot
that that was it he was retiring right
after that scene ridiculous I got a
special moment I gotta say he's have a
line in this movie he sees more in
infinity war but he's in the William
William Hurt I didn't even really know
her till I saw his name in the credits
is has been in now if you count this one
shot three of these movies and I'm it's
absurd every time he walks on and he's
really into it
and very grateful and into the whole
thing and it's like I you shouldn't be
here anyone you guys want to add Joe and
Kevin it again it's almost ever by the
way to other unsung heroes our
co-president Marvel Studios Ludi
Esposito and Victoria Alonso and our
booth these movies don't exist with
without them from Ferg for a decade but
you know that the amazing shot that Joe
Neff did at the end at Tony's funeral
that pushes past more cast members than
you might have ever seen in one shot
before by the way that's the first time
publicly or privately I've ever called
it the funeral on the call sheets in the
script it was called the wedding it was
called the wedding scene and and we
still refer to it we shot it almost two
years ago we refer to as though that
amazing day we shot the wedding shot and
it's not stitched together it's it they
were all there yeah every speaking most
valuable players Michael Grillo and Jo
Ann and Chris Castaldi there they were
all there in that in that front yard of
that cabin and and it was amazing it was
emotional for all of us you had things
like Tom Holland who played spider-man
coming up to me and going is that
Michelle Pfeiffer over there
she she and this cuz cuz we hadn't
released that man the wasp yet that was
an amazing that was an amazing day Joe
any any other cast member you wanted to
just I mean everybody's they're all
incredible I think I'd like to point out
the work of Chris Hemsworth over the
last two films infinity war in this
movie I think it's very difficult to to
be as handsome as he is and and to be to
play pathos and and humor at the same
time and be extremely vulnerable and
it's a very very rare collection of
qualities in a leading man and and I've
just found him to be exceedingly
endearing in these last two films and
he's a character that
you know that has lost almost everything
in his life and again he's played it
with a certain sense of pathos and
nobility but has made us laugh at the
same time that's it's a tone that kind
of tone is exceptionally difficult Joe
Stevie
Christopher Kevin thank you so much